right we're going down to the first year
lab to see a wonderful instrument a
musical instrument called a theremin so
this is all to do with the phenomenon of
resonance and a really neat way of
bringing across the concept of resonance
is as you'll see with this this
instrument called the theremin
developed in the 1920s by a russian
physicist called uh let's see so he was
known in russia as lev sergey ovitz
turman
aka
leon thurman in the west
so you've got a black box here you've
got an aerial here you've got a lead
coming out and you've got one knob
you don't
pluck it you don't strum it you don't
bow it you don't
hit it with your hands in fact you don't
touch it
and what you do
is actually pull notes out of the air
what i'm doing is by changing my
hand position with respect to this
antenna
you can see i'm changing the pitch of
the notes
anybody who's a led zeppelin fan will
have seen one of these jimmy page uses
these in the live version a whole lot of
love
i got this about a oh
two weeks ago now i've wanted a theremin
since i think i was about 10. um such as
such a cooling but the important thing
is that you can make all these weird
noises and i know there are some people
out there who for example might be led
zeppelin fans i might have come across a
theremin in a sort of rock concert um
forum before but in fact if you're a fan
of 60s movies if you're a fan of science
fiction the whole the entire soundtrack
to the day the earth stood still is
based around the theremin
what it is at its core is a resonant
circuit so that singing note that you
can hear
is due to the fact that we've got
um a circuit that is resonating at a
particular frequency and this idea of
resonance crops up time and time again
got this for from slovenia for my
children a few months back it's a really
quite neat demonstration of of a simple
demonstration of resonance so what we
have is a little dog on the spring this
is going to bounce up and down and it
bounces up and down at its natural
frequency
okay and if you change the mass on the
end of the
of the spring if you change the dog's
weight or get them to hold something
then
this will bounce up and down at a
different frequency or if you change
spring
constant if you change the stiffness of
the spring you'll get a different
resonant frequency how does that connect
to this instrument the way this that
connects to this instrument is that what
you have in here is a circuit that
resonates so what's resonating in that
circuit it's obviously not something
bouncing up and down
quite like this mechanically what it is
is
electric charge is sloshing about in
that circuit
and
the reason that theremin got interested
in building this particular instrument
well there are a number of different
reasons first of all his initial ideas
were not to use it as a musical
instrument but actually to detect
to detect an intruder so as you walk in
you can hear that you don't need to be
and in fact this is a relatively cheap
there i mean the the more expensive
versions
you get much greater sensitivity so the
charge the best way to think about
charge or a really good analogy to draw
is to think about how water flows so
you've got this water that's flowing
back and forth our electrons are flowing
back and forth at a particular rate
in this box we've two key things one of
which is called an inductor and that's
equivalent effectively to the mass of
this this dog and the other which is
called a capacitor and that capacitor is
related is analogous to the the
stiffness of this spring
now how how do we get these notes where
do these come from
where do we get these notes
the method by which i'm changing those
notes is by moving my hand back and
forth i'm changing capacitance of this
circuit in effect i am being part of the
capacitor okay so what's a capacitor
well a capacitor is a really really
simple electronic device or electrical
device which is just two parallel plates
best way to think about you've got two
parallel plates
and importantly those plates can store a
charge so you can charge up a capacitor
you can discharge a capacitor and it
will charge and discharge at a
particular rate
and that rate is set in this case by
we've got a capacitor in here but we
also have got another capacitor which is
given by the separation of my hand and
this area and that additional
capacitance that additional charge
storing because i'm actually there's
actually charge flowing is sets what
frequency this particular circuit will
resonate at so there isn't current as
such flowing back and forth here
but the this uh
antenna can affect the charges in may
and those charges can in turn affect the
charges here and that gives rise so
we're coupled together even though we're
not physically connected and even though
there's no electricity coupled there's
no electricity flowing across this gap
we're still coupling together what part
of one sort of integrated circuit so
when i play a note here for example
the capacitance the the distance between
my hand and this aerial means that i
affect the rate at which this charge
sloshes back and forth in the circuit
and then when i move it in
now the distance between the two plates
as would weather between this and my
hand has changed and so that resonant
frequency the capacitance has changed
therefore the rate at which charge can
slosh back and forth has changed and
therefore you hear a different note
right